hey folks Mike Row here ready to dive
into a job that's anything but soft and
fluffy today we're going to take a
closer look at the evolution of cotton
harvesting we're talking about cotton
harvesting a process that's been around
for centuries deeply rooted in our
agricultural history for a long time
picking cotton was backbreaking work
done entirely by hand it was a labor
intensive process that required a lot of
Manpower can you imagine spending hours
under the hot sun separating delicate
fibers from prickly plants it was
grueling work that tested the endurance
of even the toughest laborers it was
tough but essential the livelihoods of
many depended on this painstaking
process cotton after all is a miracle
crop its versatility and utility are
unmatched we turn it into clothes
fabrics and countless other products
that we use in our daily lives it's hard
to imagine a world without cotton but
the demand for cotton grew faster than
human hands could keep up
something had to change to meet the
increasing needs enter the cotton
harvesting machine these incredible
inventions changed the game entirely
these mechanical Marvels revolutionized
agriculture taking on the tough task of
picking cotton so we didn't have to they
increased efficiency and productivity
dramatically join me as we explore the
fascinating world of cotton harvesting
machines and learn how they transformed
this crucial industry making it more
sustainable and less labor intensive
the story of the cotton harvesting
machine is a journey of innovation and
Ingenuity a tale of human creativity
meeting agricultural necessity it all
started in the 18th century with simple
devices like the roller Jin which helped
remove seeds from the cotton fibers
making the process less labor intensive
but the real game Cher came in the 20th
century with the development of
mechanical cotton Pickers which
revolutionized the industry these early
machines were far from perfect often
breaking down in the field they were
bulky prone to breakdowns and often
damaged the delicate cotton fibers
causing frustration among Farmers but
despite their flaws they represented a
huge leap forward promising a future
where machines could handle the heavy
lifting and reduce manual labor over
time inventors and Engineers continued
to refine these machines making them
more reliable and efficient they added
features like spindles and moistening
systems to improve efficiency and
protect the quality of the cotton
ensuring a better yield and so began the
rise of the Machines forever changing
the landscape of cotton farming making
it more productive and less labor
intensive so how do these mechanical
Marvels actually work imagine a giant
vacuum cleaner moving through a field of
cotton okay it's a bit more complicated
than that but you get the idea modern
cotton Harvesters are equipped with rows
of rotating spindles or brushes these
spindles reach out and gently twist the
cotton fibers separating them from the
plant without damaging the precious crop
the detached cotton is then drawn into
the machine where it's cleaned and
compressed into large Bales some
Harvesters even use air suction to pull
the cotton from the plant a bit like
that giant vacuum cleaner we talked
about it's a fascinating process to
watch a blend of brute force and
delicate
Precision now let's take a break from
the machinery and talk cotton trivia did
you know that a single cotton plant can
produce up to 50 cotton bowls that's a
lot of fluffy goodness and speaking of
fluffy did you know that cotton is
naturally hypoallergenic that's why it's
often used in bedding and clothing for
people with sensitive skin here's
another fun fact the average cotton
t-shirt requires about 2,700 L of water
to produce that's a lot of H2O which is
why sustainable cotton farming practices
are so important from its incredible
versatility to its surprising water
footprint cotton is a crop full of
fascinating
facts section five the impact a world
transformed the introduction of cotton
harvesting machines had a profound
impact on agriculture and Beyond before
these machines cotton farming was
incredibly labor intensive it took
hundreds of workers to harvest a large
field and the work was slow and
physically demanding but with machines
doing the heavy lifting Farmers could
Harvest vast fields of cotton with fewer
workers and in a fraction of the time
this increased efficiency led to a
dramatic increase in Cotton production
making cotton more affordable and
accessible to people around the world
the mechanization of cotton harvesting
also had social and economic
consequences changing the face of rural
communities and sparking debates about
Labor displacement that continue to this
day section six beyond the fields
Cotton's Journey continues once the
cotton is harvested its journey is far
from Over The Fluffy fibers are
transported to processing plants where
they undergo a series of cleaning and
preparation steps first the cotton is
cleaned to remove dirt leaves and other
debris that may have been collected
during harvesting next the cotton fibers
are aligned and straightened through a
process called cting then comes spinning
where the fibers are twisted together to
create yarn this yarn can then be woven
or knitted into Fabrics ready to be
transformed into clothing Linens and
countless other products it's a complex
and fascinating process that showcases
the incredible versatility of this
natural
fiber section seven challenges and
Innovations the future of cotton
harvesting while cotton harvesting
machines have come a long way the Quest
for improvement never stops researchers
and Engineers are constantly working to
develop new technologies and techniques
to make cotton harvesting even more
efficient and sustainable one area of
focus is precision agriculture which
uses sensors and data analysis to
optimize harvesting practices and reduce
waste imagine a cotton picker that can
analyze each plant and determine the
optimal time to harvest ensuring the
highest quality cotton while minimizing
environmental impact other Innovations
include robotic Harvesters and drones
that can assist with harvesting and
monitoring crops the future of cotton
harvesting is full of exciting
[Music]
possibilities Section 8 cotton and our
world a lasting Legacy from the close we
wear to the sheets we sleep on Cotton is
an integral part of our daily lives
providing comfort and utility in
countless ways the story of cotton
harvesting is a testament to human
Ingenuity and our ongoing quest to
improve the world around us showcasing
our ability to innovate and adapt what
started as backbreaking manual labor has
been transformed by technology making
cotton more accessible and affordable
for people worldwide revolutionizing the
industry but the journey doesn't end
there the evolution of cotton harvesting
continues to unfold driven by new
challenges and opportunities as we Face
Global challenges like climate change
and resource scarcity it's more
important than ever to find Sustainable
Solutions for cotton farming and
production ensuring a balance with
nature by supporting ethical and
environmentally conscious practices we
can ensure that cotton continues to be a
valuable and sustainable resource for
generations to come preserving its
Legacy section n the end of the row or
just the beginning so there you have it
folks a glimpse into the amazing world
of cotton harvesting from the early days
of handpicking to the high-tech Machines
of today we've come a long way but the
story of cotton is far from over as
technology continues to evolve and our
understanding of sustainable practices
grows who knows what the future holds
for this incredible crop one thing's for
sure the journey will continue to be
fascinating until next time keep your
curiosity alive and your work ethics
strong this is Mike Row signing off